this lesson will focus on reactions of
carboxylic acid derivatives but to
understand why the derivatives are
important it's useful to look at the
reactions of carboxylic acids first so
we're going to look at a few reactions
at carboxylic acids undergo to begin
this first reaction called the Fischer
esterification converts a carboxylic
acid into an ester it's very important
that this is performed under acidic
conditions so we have sulfuric acid in
here h2 so4 and whatever alcohol we use
here we have ethanol abbreviated h OE T
I could have written it EtOH if you're
used to seeing it that way that will
replace the O H group here it's very
important that this has carried out an
acid because everything stays protonated
that's the only way we can really get a
carboxylic acid to swap out the group
and convert into an ester you'll see why
in just a moment often this reaction is
heated and sometimes a special apparatus
called a dean-stark trap is used to
remove water we're losing a molecule of
water from the carboxylic acid so if we
can remove that we can push the reaction
in this direction and form our ester in
good yield the second reaction that
we'll review occurs when we treat a
carboxylic acid with a nucleophile here
we're going to use ammonia ammonia has a
lone pair of electrons on the nitrogen
now if we're thinking back to reactions
of aldehydes and ketones we might think
that our nucleophile will attack at the
carbonyl carbon however we have a
different situation here the O h of the
carboxylic acid is quite acidic it has a
pKa of around 4.6 in water and so
instead of any attack happening at this
carbonyl we're simply going to get
deprotonation to form a salt the lone
pair on ammonia can grab the proton will
draw a second arrow to show the Oh H
bond becoming a lone pair on oxygen and
we produce our salt here I'm showing the
appropriate charges on these atoms
sometimes you'll just see this all drawn
Oh nh4 and you'll have to know that that
is the salt there the third reaction
that's important for today's lesson is
the conversion of a carboxylic acid into
this functional group which is called an
acid chloride this can be accomplished
using the reagent thionyl chloride or
phosphorus pentachloride so we've
introduced one carboxylic acid
derivative and we see the Oh H is
replaced by a chlorine that's called an
acid chloride and let's begin making a
list of these carboxylic acid
derivatives in our acid chloride we have
a chlorine atom in place of the O H
group our next derivative is an acid
anhydride or you can just call it an
anhydride here the O H is replaced by
this o acetyl group another carboxylic
acid derivative is the ester which we
actually met up here we were forming an
ester in this Fischer esterification
reaction and so here we're showing an
ethyl ester and here I've just drawn a
one stick for a methyl ester the final
common example of a carboxylic acid
derivative that we'll go over in this
lesson is the amat we have a nitrogen
replacing the O H group here and I've
shown this with two methyls and amat can
have hydrogen's or alkyl groups on the
nitrogen
no I've arranged these in order from the
most reactive to the least reactive of
the derivatives chlorine is in the row
below carbon on the periodic table this
is a larger atom and so we don't have as
good of orbital overlap so the resonance
contribution of the electrons on
chlorine kind of pushing up into that
double bond isn't so great but with the
ester namet we have a lot of
delocalization here particularly with
the a m''d we can show the lone pair on
nitrogen participating in favorable
resonance with the carbonyl oxygen
following our arrow pushing look at this
resonance form and this is a pretty good
resonance structure we've got a negative
charge on the electronegative oxygen
we have an octet around nitrogen and so
this form contributes significantly to
the structure of the amat this is
important because the major reaction of
these derivatives is the addition of a
nucleophile to the carbonyl oxygen with
loss of this group here let's take a
look at just a general mechanism for
these derivatives I'm going to draw a
generic structure for our carboxylic
acid derivative what I'm abbreviating LG
is a leaving group each of these
derivatives has a potential leaving
group in the molecule let me go ahead
and label those for you when our
carboxylic acid derivative is treated
with an appropriate nucleophile a
nucleophile that's strong enough to
displace this group in the derivative
you imagine you'll need stronger
nucleophiles here and weaker
nucleophiles will be fine with these
more reactive derivatives what's going
to happen in the first step is similar
to the reaction we've seen with
aldehydes and ketones the nucleophile is
going to attack the carbonyl group
pushing the electrons up onto oxygen
this intermediate here has a special
name it's called a tetrahedral
intermediate and that reflects what's
going on in the mechanism we have this
sp2 center here going from sp2 getting
added to by the nucleophile and then
going to sp3 sp3 carbon is of course a
tetrahedral geometry so we call this the
tetrahedral intermediate you might have
guessed this from the fact that I'm
calling this a leaving group or the fact
that this is a tetrahedral intermediate
but the reaction doesn't stop here the
tetrahedral intermediate is not a stable
compound and so these electrons are
going to push back down from oxygen and
eliminate our leaving group and the
overall result of our reaction is the
formation of a carbonyl compound
substituted with our nucleophile and we
also get our leaving group off by itself
now for this general mechanism I showed
a basic nucleophile it has a negative
charge
extra electrons here attacking the
carbonyl so that happens with a direct
attack in this first step some of the
reactions of functional derivatives will
be acid catalyzed so you'll want to look
up those mechanisms the big difference
is we're going to get protonation of the
carbonyl oxygen first by the acid and
then the nucleophile can attack well now
that I've drawn this general mechanism
you might be like what the heck is the
nucleophile that's a good question and
brings up an important point we can go
from these more reactive functional
derivatives in this direction so the
acid chloride can be converted to an end
hydride it can be converted to an ester
it can be converted to an amide the
anhydride can be converted to an ester
or an amide but we cannot go this way so
an amat cannot be converted to an ester
by this mechanism nor can it be
converted to an acid chloride or
anhydride so in interpreting this table
any of these compounds can be converted
to all of the compounds to the right of
it however they can't be converted to
the compound on the Left let's look at
some actual examples of these reactions
an acid chloride can be treated with the
sodium salt of a carboxylic acid the o-
will be the nucleophile will form our
tetrahedral intermediate and after
collapse of the tetrahedral intermediate
will produce an anhydride beginning
again with our acid chloride we're going
to convert this into an ester can you
think of a possible reactant to form
this methyl ester here this is commonly
done using the alcohol and we need to
add in a base pyridine or triethylamine
we'll do the product of this reaction is
of course our ester and we also get an
ammonium chloride salt out of this it's
important to use the amine base
otherwise we would form HCl from these
two reactants and that can actually
potentially lead to hydrolysis of the
ester product we just don't want any HCL
forming in the rear
finally we can treat our acid chloride
with 2 moles of ammonia this will
produce our a mad functional group and a
molecule of ammonium chloride again this
is a salt and if I wanted to make that
really obvious I can put charges on the
appropriate atoms so far we've only
shown this generic mechanism so let's go
ahead and do the mechanism for this
reaction so you can see a specific one
in the first step of the mechanism our
acid chloride reacts with the molecule
of methanol the electrons on oxygen
perform nucleophilic attack on the
carbonyl carbon we don't want to make
five bonds to carbon so we push our
electrons up onto oxygen this gives the
tetrahedral intermediate I chose this
mechanism because it allows me to make
an important point here notice I have
this attacking first the base is not
pulling a proton off of this alcohol to
start our alcohol has a pKa of around Oh
15 and 1/2 16 and triethylamine iam the
conjugate acid of this has a PKA around
9 or 10 and so this is the stronger acid
so it's going to prefer to be in this
form in this equilibrium so the triethyl
ammonium has a pKa of let's say 10 this
has a pKa of let's say 16 and so this
likes to be deprotonated lower PKA more
than this so it's not until we get this
attack that we get something so acidic
that the triethylamine can finally come
in and grab that proton so we have to
think about our PK's of all our
conjugate acids in the solution and
consider when the deprotonation is going
to occur and that's going to occur after
this attack step but even before the
deprotonation we need to collapse our
tetrahedral intermediate pushing these
electrons down and kicking out chlorine
the reason this happens before
deprotonation is this is unstable and it
can kick this out in an intramolecular
process to do the deprotonation we need
something in
termolecular happening and so that's
going to happen slower in solution so
collapse the tetrahedral intermediate to
give this compound and a molecule of CL
minus and now our triethylamine can come
in this has a negative PK a so this
triethylamine is going to be basic
enough now to take off this proton and
produce our ester plus a molecule of tri
ethyl ammonium chloride let's just
quickly look at a couple more reaction
examples since we've only focused on
acid chlorides our anhydride can react
with an alcohol here I'm using benzyl
alcohol and we'll get cleavage of this
bond here knocking off the leaving group
alternatively it could happen on this
side just depending on which carbonyl
group gets attacked I'll show my little
squiggly line here just to show you
where the bond breaks this will produce
an ester and a molecule of acetic acid
and I want to make note that this oxygen
here in the product is this oxygen since
this is the one attacking here so maybe
we'll just highlight that in pink and
this acetic acid molecule is coming from
this being cleaved here esters can react
with a means to produce an ax and a
molecule of ethanol okay so what happens
if you're approaching a problem or
sitting in an exam and they give you an
amide and ask you to form one of the
less reactive functional derivatives
what is our strategy going to be well
I'm going to introduce one more reaction
that will allow you to work around this
problem every one of these functional
derivatives can undergo hydrolysis to
produce a carboxylic acid so here are
four carboxylic acid derivatives in the
presence of water on these two
carboxylic acid derivatives the acid
chloride and anhydride will smoothly
hydrolyze just in water our ester and
ammon might need a little kick so
sometimes you might see these hydrolysis
reactions for the less reactive
functional derivatives
formed with a little bit of acid or base
so let me just put that in parentheses
under the arrow and this will give a
carboxylic acid under acidic conditions
and if we're under these basic
conditions of course we'll produce the
carboxylate salt the salt can be
converted to the acid by treatment with
an equivalent of acid now this is where
our third reaction becomes very
important carboxylic acids you know with
nucleophiles they deprotonate and then
once you make this negative thing
nothing wants to attack at this carbonyl
because we have all this repulsion from
the negative charge so no nucleophile
under normal conditions is really going
to be able to attack here but we have
this reaction in which we convert a
carboxylic acid to the most reactive of
the functional derivatives so imagine
we're given an amen' and we want to
convert this to this ester we can first
hydrolyze our amma to the carboxylic
acid treat this with thionyl chloride or
phosphorus pentachloride produce our
acid chloride and convert that to our
methyl ester by treatment with methanol
and we'll use pyridine as a base this
time this produces our desired ester and
a molecule of this pyridinium chloride
salt